[Music]
jenny is in denver hi jenny welcome to
the ramsay show
hi guys great to talk to you my question
is
should i allow my 25 year old daughter
to use money that was intended for
college to pay off her credit card debt
so where where is this money parked
it is in mutual funds and a brokerage
account um
that she
doesn't have access to even though she's
over 21 but
we've kind of kept that because we don't
think
she's ready for it how much credit card
debt is this
she has about eight thousand in credit
card debt and three thousand dollars in
the student loan that she never took any
classes for
oh
so she's already how much money how much
money is in this quote college fund
um it was given to her by grandmother
and it's 130 000 total um my husband i
actually put in about 20 000 of it but
whose name is it in
it's under her name and it's not under
529 or anything but that was the intent
when she was a baby
and she's already finished with college
my husband and i paid for her college
oh she did and you paid for it well good
for her
okay so um
you're the custodian on the account
um well not officially anymore but um
yeah they gave that they say
um they don't you don't think they can
handle it they might not know the
password etc
okay
so
you're basically keeping her money from
her to protect her from her is what
you're saying
i'm correct you haven't seen this okay
so what does she what behaviors are she
is she engaged in that
make you think she's not capable of
handling this
um
she she's recently unemployed which is
why she asked us about it um because i
think um she's getting you know kind of
stressed out but anyway um she spends a
lot of money
um we've asked her to take your class
but she won't do it she won't
talk to us about
sitting down with us and doing a budget
and she she's learned all this as a kid
and in high school or school taught your
class but um she just seems to spend as
fast as she can it seems
that's my concern is if you clean up the
8 000 with this fund she may just rack
up another 8 000. there's no lessons
learned here
that's my concern and you know yet she's
25 years old i'm not sure exactly
you know what what place i have in
yeah i mean
there's two sides to this equation right
now i mean there's a side where there's
a concerned mom
who doesn't want her daughter to blow
130 000 and look back and regret it
uh there's another side if she figures
out that money's there
uh and you don't give it to her
instantly
she's gonna sue your butt and win
this is not your money you don't legally
have control of it anymore
right you're just you're just you're
just trying to do a little
smoking mirrors here to keep your hands
off it so i mean you've got to balance
this a little bit between the fact that
um what you're doing is for her own good
uh but you're not gonna get away with it
forever
correct yeah i know that it's not in a
trust
no
it's simply in her it's simply her bank
account she doesn't have the password
yes
i feel bad about that i do but i i kind
of do but i kind of don't i'm with you
i'm kind i mean i love the fact that
you're trying to help her
uh but i don't know how much longer we
can babysit this child
um and not get yourself in trouble in
the process
okay so uh why do you think you guys
have been unable to persuade her to grow
up
um
she's pretty hard-headed and
has a lot of different value systems
than
she was brought up with and what her dad
and i have and i think she doesn't want
to listen to us
so you've really lost the ability to
have a reasonable dialogue
yes
um
i don't know how to answer this for sure
i'm trying to think about it live here
on the air with 22 million people
listening at the moment
while i'm hesitating and stumbling
because i i actually agree with both
sides of this equation
um
what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes
well number one i'd be crying a lot
because this is such a disappointing
horrible situation
number two i probably would have done
what you have done to this point i often
told my kids that you won't find this uh
uniform transfer to miners act account
if you're doing heroin or running around
and living on the back of a yacht like
you're some kind of a reality star you
just won't know it's there good luck
i'll never give it to you and i told
them that uh however we're down to four
years over time
that she is legally in control of this
account if she ever gets this
um
man you could get yourself in a mess
here
so i'm about ready to hand this i'm
about ready to hand this account to this
kid and just wash my hands
and go you know what
you are you are a mess and you're gonna
make a mess with this and i am disgusted
and i hate it because i think i'm doing
you harm and as your mom it makes me cry
but you know
you just don't have the values and
you're about to mess this up i know
you're going to and i'm i wish you
wouldn't i wish you'd go to financial
peace university i wish you'd grow up
and turn this in money that your
grandmother left you but she's gonna
because your grandmother's gonna be in
heaven shaking her head she's ashamed of
you and i'm i'm ashamed i'm ashamed oh
okay we're all we're all ashamed of your
behavior will she talk to her
grandmother
um say i'm sorry dave would she talk to
her grandmother
yeah she i mean not about that um her
grandmother gave her five thousand
dollars last year to clean up the debt
and but will her grandmother knock a
noggin on her knock knock a knot on her
yeah i can i could ask for that
she might hear she she's probably done
with you is what i sounds like i'm
hearing
with you telling her what to do
but maybe granny can get away with it
because granny put most of this money in
there
you know another yeah i
uh you you there's legal issues involved
here
okay okay and then there's the moral
issue of whether you're gonna bring harm
to your child if i was the grandparent
i'd be asking you to transfer me the
uh password and i'd take the money back
and i would say get after it kiddo sue
me i ain't giving you nothing and i
would knock a knot on her if i was the
granddaddy
grandma yeah now mom and dad might be
different but good luck suing your
grandma oh i wouldn't do that that
that's that's a special place in hell
right there
oh my gosh
but uh yeah you got legal issues because
you guys put the money in her name